[Applause]
so quantum mechanics is the subject of
the discussion here tonight and look
it's the year
2014 and the first glimmers of quantum
mechanics really came on the scene in
the early part of the 20th century
certainly by
1930 or so the basic framework of
quantum mechanics was in place and yet
today
right some 80 years later there are
still questions that are ripe for
discussion at the foundation of the
subject
questions that are still controversial
and we're going to discuss one of those
controversial questions here tonight so
you'll see various perspectives on that
at the same time
quantum mechanics of all the subjects of
modern physics has really been embraced
by the culture at least the language of
quantum mechanics has been embraced by
the culture i mean i mean just to give a
couple examples right except from
hollywood right we have we have quantum
thrillers right
we also have you know quantum sporting
goods right golf clubs quantum bowling
balls quantum baseball we've got quantum
cartoons right oh alice you're the one
for me but bob in a quantum world how
can we be sure
and then we have physicists talking
dirty right uh i'd like to cover you in
quantum foam and
you finish it i'm not giving i uh
the family program here right so we also
have
quantum health care right so this one
quantum herbal canker sword gel
nothing to do with the previous cartoon
completely
separate we have the quantum pendant
protects the body against any harmful
rays i like this one we got the quantum
vet right
use your cell phone to instantly
diagnose and medically treat your pet at
home and i love this tag line over here
you see it at the bottom
don't take me to the vet
use quantum vet
which makes use of that famous of all
adages which is a surefire way to get
words to rhyme
is to use the same word
now this this one is absolutely my
favorite
the quantum sleeper
protection from biochemical terrorist
attack kidnappers stalkers
bulletproof and look how look at the
loving couple over there about to enter
the sarcophagus over there right so so
quantum mechanics in this sense is
certainly out there in the world but of
course this is just the word quantum
this is really
quantum [ __ ] right so um
what we're going to talk about here
tonight is the real quantum mechanics
and what i'm going to do here for just
about 10 12 minutes
is run through
the basic ideas of quantum mechanics
again i think that's probably familiar
to many of you
but just to make sure that we're all on
the same page and that will naturally
lead us in
to the issue for tonight's discussion
which is this quantum measurement
problem okay so for the basic
primer on quantum mechanics the key
experiment that really gets the ideas of
quantum mechanics across is the double
slit experiment
and i don't know did any of you go to
spooky action last year just by any
chance yeah so a handful of you so you
may recall that we actually did the
double slit experiment on the stage last
year we're not going to do it again this
year we don't have enough time but
rather animations will give you the
essential ideas and if anyone doesn't
believe the animations just ask someone
whose hand was up because they saw the
real experiment done last year okay so
what is a double slit experiment the
idea is this
imagine that i have
a gun that's firing ordinary
pellets like bbs at a barrier that has
two openings now you'd expect that those
bbs that go through the left slit will
land aligned in a band on the left those
pellets that go through the right
opening will land in a band aligned with
it on the right and indeed were you to
do this experiment that is the result
that you would find
now what we're going to do is imagine
dialing down the size of those pellets
those bbs making them smaller and
smaller until they are the size of
little tiny particles let's just call
them electrons imagine we're doing this
with electrons well you'd expect that if
you run the same
experiment again those electrons that
pass through the left opening will land
in a band aligned with the opening on
the left and similarly for those that
pass through the right that is what you
would expect should
happen and i think as many of you are
familiar this is not what happens when
you do this experiment instead if you do
this experiment you get results that
look rather different they look like
this
you get a bright band next to a dark
region next to a bright region next to a
dark region next to a bright region and
so forth and that data that strange data
is really what impels us toward quantum
mechanics now that data is
strange because it's not what we would
think should happen we expect to get two
bands
and we get more but it turns out that
that pattern bright dark bright dark is
a familiar pattern to
most physicists i mean we are trained
from birth to recognize that pattern
right if you were to go
to any physicist three o'clock in the
morning shake that physicist wake them
up and tell them i got this data bright
band dark brown bright brand dark brand
the very first thing that they would say
to you is
what the hell are you doing in my room
at three o'clock in the morning
but after that they would say i know
what that is
that's an interference pattern that is
the hallmark signature that there's some
kind of wave phenomenon some kind of
wave phenomenon taking place right to
understand that let me just give you a
little visual here
where we're looking at water waves
imagine i throw two pebbles the first
one over here makes these circular
ripples i'm now throwing a second one
and look what happens
when the waves overlap in some regions
they work together but in other regions
the peak of one wave is crossing the
trough of another causing the wave to
cancel out and those are those dark
regions that you see
on
the screen
so this is exactly the kind of data that
we're encountering and to make that
point a little bit more clearly let me
just show you an animation same idea
imagine you've got water waves going
toward the barrier with the two openings
and again regions where the waves work
together the water is very agitated
regions in between where the peak of one
wave crosses the trough of the other
they cancel each other out and if on the
back screen i put bright regions
associated with very agitated water dark
regions with not agitated water look
what i get bright dark bright dark
bright
dark
and again just to remember that is
the data that we find in this experiment
so this suggests
that there is some deep connection
between
these particles these electrons and this
other idea a completely separate idea
of waves now at first sight that might
not actually seem
all that surprising right because water
has water waves but we all know that
water is itself made of little particles
molecules h2o molecules so certainly we
know that if a large collection
of molecules behaves in a choreographed
manner
those particles can yield a wave
so maybe what's going on in the
experiment is just that you've got a lot
of electrons and maybe they are behaving
in a choreographed manner and that way
yielding a wave just like h2o molecules
yield a water wave now how would you
test that idea
well you can run this very experiment
but only firing particle by single
particle at this barrier with the two
openings and recording dot by single dot
where each of those single particles
lands on the detector screen so let's
run that version of the experiment
and see what happens so again
particle by single particle we're
recording on the back screen
the history of all the landing locations
and this is what happens in this
experiment
dot by single dot we build up the same
pattern the same interference pattern
the same
data that suggests to us that there must
be some kind of wave-like phenomenon
involved to yield
this interference
pattern so this is where things get
really strange
particles electrons little tiny dot that
is the image that we always have in mind
waves are these spread out
entities
how could a dot particle and a spread
out wave somehow be
connected and this was the puzzle that
physicists faced in the early decades of
the 20th century and many tried to
figure out what could the connection
between a particle and a wave b and the
natural suggestion that you might throw
out is you know maybe particles somehow
are kind of kind of smeared out in some
way they're kind of spread out in a way
that we didn't realize
that idea though doesn't really work
because whenever you measure an electron
you find all of it if it was truly
smeared out you'd find a piece of it
here and a piece of it there
and the idea that ultimately
was settled upon
came from the mind
of a physicist max born was that the way
to think about the wave associated with
the particle is this this is the new
idea
the wave is a wave of probability
the wave is telling us the likelihood
the probability that the particle's at
one location or another so to show you a
little visual of that imagine this is
the wave associated with a particle like
an electron where the wave is big
that's a likely location to find the
particle where the wave is small
an unlikely location and where the wave
is absolutely zero
that is a place where you simply will
not find the electron at all
that's the picture that comes forward
now how would you test this idea to see
if it's actually describing in reality
how the world works well the first thing
is you need some kind of mathematical
equation that allows you to understand
how this wave evolves how it changes
over time and that equation
came to us
from erwin schroedinger whether you
understand the mathematical symbols or
not it doesn't matter but it's good to
see that there is a bona fide rigorous
mathematical equation behind all of the
imagery that you'll be seeing here
tonight that is the equation
that describes how
this wave this probability wave evolves
over time that's step one so now you
understand how things change in time but
to test it well you say to yourself this
look if at a given moment in time i've
got this
probability profile for where a particle
should be located the way i test it is i
run the experiment of searching for the
particle over and over again in
identically prepared situations
and
i count up the number of times i find it
in one location or another and if the
theory is correct
you should find the particle
more often where the wave is big and
less often where the wave is small so we
can run that little
experiment right here so this is a
simplified probability wave the blue
curve and each of the x's is the result
of an experiment looking for the
location of a particle and you see over
many many many runs of the experiment
where you record all of the locations
where you find the particle over time
they fill out exactly
the probability profile that comes from
the mathematical equation
and that agreement between experiment
and theory is what gives us confidence
that these ideas are actually describing
how
the world works so just to kind of close
the loop on this going back to the
double slit experiment how we we
describe it well in this new language
the electron should be thought of as a
probability wave which hits the barrier
with the two openings and much like a
water wave when the wave goes through it
interferes creates this pattern of
way locations where the wave is big or
the wave is small and those locations
dictate the likelihood or not of an
electron landing in one of those regions
so now if we run the experiment with the
little particles going out
dot by single dot they're going to fill
out that probability profile where the
wave is big they're going to be many
electrons landing where the wave is
small very few and where the wave was
zero the dark locations
no locations will be occupied by an
electron at all
so this is
the basic reason
why we believe that these ideas
are correct so what this means is
by
year 1930 or so
these individuals the pioneers of
quantum mechanics and others as well
these are
we have over here max planck we have
albert einstein niels warr werner
heisenberg robin williams um
um
um you know erwin schrodinger kind of
looks like
robin williams there
so these fellas here
develop this structure which
seems
very odd but able to describe the data
okay so that's the good part of the
story
now for the question that will occupy us
here tonight which is this
when we talk about say
the motion of a particle like an
electron we describe it in this wave
like manner
it could be at one location or another
or another still but when we actually
measure the electron we find it at one
single location
when we find it at one single location
we know where it is
which suggests that it must be the case
that the probability wave has now spiked
at that location because we know where
the electron
is the problem is
this notion of the active measurement
affecting the probability wave in that
manner
does not agree with the mathematical
equation so we'll talk about this in
more detail in just a moment in fact
when you look at the mathematics or in
fact when you think it through
even just
recognizing
that when we make an observation we use
a piece of equipment that piece of
equipment is itself made up the very
same particles electrons and protons and
neutrons the same particles that we use
the quantum language to describe
and therefore if we have a situation say
where the probability wave for an
electron has
some
non-trivial value in one location and
some non-trivial value in another
location and we go to measure the
position of that particle well the
measuring equipment should be sensitive
to those two components of the
probability wave and therefore in some
sense should register both of those
outcomes at the same time
and that is something that never happens
we never look at a measuring device and
somehow it is confused
in
giving us information about the location
of a particle
that is the quantum measurement problem
how do we go
from the spread out probability wave
which tells us a particle can be here or
there or here or there to the single
definite reality that we all experience
how do we navigate from the place of
probability to the place of definite
reality that is the question and
thankfully we have some of the world's
experts joining us here tonight to
describe various possible solutions to
that puzzle
so without further ado
i'd like to bring them onto the stage
all right our first participant
a philosopher at columbia university
renowned for his insights into
philosophical questions about time and
space modern physics author of quantum
mechanics and experience time and chance
and soon after physics will be released
this fall please welcome david albert
[Applause]
also joining us a mathematician
physicist and philosopher at rutgers
university studies the foundations of
quantum theory probability theory and
statistical mechanics co-author of
quantum physics without quantum
philosophy please welcome sheldon
goldstein
[Applause]
our third participant theoretical
physicist at the california institute of
technology and author
of the award-winning the particle at the
end of the universe his research covers
cosmology field theory dark energy
particle physics and gravitation just
about everything else on planet earth
please welcome my friend sean carroll
[Applause]
all right our final participant
mathematician at royal holloway
university of london
leading proponent along with chris fuchs
of a new view of quantum mechanics known
as cubism
please welcome the man with the coolest
name in the history of physics rudiger
shack
[Applause]
all right let's uh jump in
i'm gonna arrange the evening in three
chapters
and chapter one as we see here we're
going to discuss the quantum algorithm
and its discontents
all right so just to get us going i want
us to cast our mind back to
you know the early years of the 20th
century
look at what we've done right we had
classical mechanics we could describe
the motion of planets we could describe
the motion of objects around us we had
maxwell's equations we understood
electricity and magnetism
and all of a sudden the experiments that
i was talking about just a minute ago
kind of ripped all that out from under
us and we had this new quantum
perspective that came online so sean
just
imagine you were back there right and
you'd love this classical world that had
come down to us from the greats of
newton and maxwell what would it have
been like to try to take on board these
new ideas i think that the fact that we
came to invent and accept quantum
mechanics as quickly as we did
or this is the very royal we including
people in the past uh is one of the most
impressive intellectual accomplishments
in the entire history of the human race
because
every idea that was part of quantum
mechanics just seemed to violate some
cherished notion that we had really
clung to you know we had this paradigm
handed down by galileo and newton and
their friends and that was how physics
was done and it was a matter of which
version of that physics we should accept
and quantum mechanics comes along and
just changes all of the rules so it must
have been a combination of incredibly
exciting and more than a little dizzying
and people must have been pinching
themselves a little bit and like
wondering have we gone terribly wrong
and thinking about this yeah so i think
all of us have heard that einstein
had his
various tensions with quantum mechanics
rudiger where do you where does that
come from why did einstein
have this ultimate dislike for for
quantum theory
einstein had a notion
of
physical reality that clashed with the
ideas of quantum mechanics just as as
sean just um
mentioned
and quantum mechanics has
some strange features if you
think of um
um quantum states as as real as
describing the swiping reality and you
have situations where taking an action
here
or let's say make it more dramatic take
an action as far away as on a on a
spaceship near sirius
um appears to have an immediate
instantaneous effect
on my system uh here if the if the state
of these two systems is entangled now
that um
that clashed with einstein's sense of
reality and ancient sense of of of of
locality now i think you raise that that
issue because later in the evening
you're going to give us your solution to
that particular problem which is a good
one we're going to come to that in due
course let's build up to it step by step
so so david and shelly you know when i
took quantum mechanics it was it was the
1980s
and i think probably we're all roughly
within 10 years of each other so we all
were taking it after the kind of dust of
the revolution had settled and i took it
from a fellow who ultimately won the
nobel prize norman ramsey
great great physicist great teacher
and here's what he taught me right so if
we can just bring up the approach to
quantum mechanics that i was taught so
we're told we had the input of how
things are right now and the idea was
that we then were to make use of this
equation that i mentioned before the
schrodinger equation and using that we
would be able to predict
the probability of what things there
weren't actually all those fireworks but
the probability of how things will be
in the future and for those who like a
little bit of the equations again it
does not matter at all if you don't
follow the equations but it's kind of
good to see them you start with a
probability wave or more precisely a
wave function at some initial time you
stick it into this equation
and then you get this output equation
which is the probability for how things
will be later this is what i was taught
i studied it hard right i did well on
all the exams
is this it
is there some problem with this way of
thinking about things
you wanna i mean
i can start it's it's it's
what you wanna know
um i think typically in sign
is when you see behaviors when you see
behaviors that are aptly summarized
by equations like this the natural thing
to do
is to ask yourself a question of the
form
what would the world have to be like
or what could the world be like
such that a procedure like this
correctly predicts what you're going to
see um
what you're the business you're usually
about in doing science is asking about
how the world is um
there are various
kinds of ways in which the world can
confront you such as to raise questions
like that and what happened in quantum
mechanics as you say is that we had this
algorithm
that was enormously successful in
predicting how experiments were going to
come out but the algorithm didn't seem
at first glance to readily lend itself
to some kind of story
about
how the world needed to be
such that an algorithm like this was
going to be successful right so actually
i just alerted there's a question along
these lines let me just quickly get in
here from sam g from twitter
says that you know if there is an issue
here along the lines of what you're
suggesting we're going to make that
issue even more explicit as we go
forward
why are students taught
this and not taught the actual issue
itself is it expedience is it you need
to learn it first this way and then
later on once you grasp it the problems
can well perhaps maybe the
our physic the physics teachers want the
students to have the same bewildering
experience
[Laughter]
so let's make that that bewilderment
even a little bit more clear so i was
mentioned before the quantum measurement
problem
how how would shell how would you
describe the measurement problem
well
i guess
your um graphics before with the too
slidic experiment did a really good job
i mean
you had the wave you have an equation
for the wave
you call it a probability wave but if it
really were a probability wave it should
be for the probability of something and
there might if it's the probability for
the position of the particle
that should be a particle with a
position so let's not take the word
probability wave too seriously let's
just call it we have a wave but if we
have just a wave and this wave is going
through both slits then this wave is
spread out it develops an interference
pattern but it's still spread out so why
does anything dot like appear at the
screen that's where
the act of observation of measurement
has to play a special role of causing
that wave that fundamental equation to
break down and the wave to collapse
i think what einstein regarded as the
real problem with quantum mechanics what
he was so dissatisfied with was that the
observer seemed to play a fundamental
role
observers are after all just made of the
same stuff everything else is made of
why should there be different laws which
have to be invoked to deal with the
observer that was really what
einstein right so the idea is you got to
spread out wave
and thereby in some sense the particle
could be many locations but yet when
it's measured you find it at one
definite spot
how well and as you said brian earlier
during the introduction if you were to
treat the measuring apparatus
straightforwardly in exactly the same
way as you treat the particle it's
perfectly clear what these algorithms
predict they'll you you have the
particle in in a superposition i don't
know if we use that word or not not yet
but in a superposition of being here and
here a combination of being some kind of
combination or some kind of situation
in which it's neither here nor there nor
in both places nor in neither place but
something else involving these two
locations um and if you
straightforwardly apply these equations
um if you treat the measuring apparatus
as just an assemblage of such particles
which is the way we've always treated
such objects in the history of science
um you're going to very
straightforwardly get a result and it
was people like schrodinger and von
neumann who first showed this very
rigorously
you're going to get the result
of the the measuring device being in a
superposition of having registered the
particle being here and having
registered the particle being there and
the same would apply for example to the
brain of the conscious observer who
looks at the measuring device let me
show you a little visual that we have
just to emphasize that point the quantum
measurement problem so exactly the ones
of what you're describing imagine i have
a a tabletop
model of manhattan right and i have a
particle whose wave function is
probability of being at any given
location is described by that curve
right then i bring in a measuring device
this guy over here and it measures that
particle's position and let's say it
finds it at the belvedere castle right
for those of you out of town 79th street
central park very nice place to visit
but that's all a different story okay so
that is measurement number one let's now
imagine that we have a
probability wave that looks like this
and we perform a measurement as well in
exactly the same manner so we bring in
our measuring device
and the measuring device shows that that
particle is located now at union square
14th street good okay now to the
situation that you're talking about
let's imagine that we have a combination
of these two a superposition a
combination of these two situations
where this is what the probability wave
looks like we bring in our measuring
device
and as you were saying since it's made
of atoms and particles it should be
sensitive to those two locations and
therefore the output should be
you know something like that right a
mixture of these two possibilities
but whenever we actually perform in a
measurement like this we never see that
happen with our devices our brains seem
never to be cognizant of that kind of
confusion and that is the issue that we
want to resolve and maybe it's worth
saying
that we do sometimes do these
measurements in situations where we're
confident that before we did the
measurement the wave function really did
look like this two peaked yes yes so we
can really in a sense set up exactly
what we're talking about over here all
right so i think my understanding is
there are probably three of us on the
stage who are sympathetic to this issue
right so david you think this is an
issue shel you think this is an issue
yes oh yeah that's what the philosophy
is you never get like just that yes i
you gotta qualify it yeah it's i think
it but i think it's i do think it's an
issue but oh but i think it's an issue
for odd historical reasons i i i we will
come to that yes absolutely good sean
issue
i think it's an issue that we can solve
yeah okay good and now rudiger you think
it may even be a non-issue at some
level or
or just that you can solve it too
well i i would regard it as an issue
that originally didn't exist but then um
sort of the in quantum mechanics was
interpreted in a way that created the
issue okay so it's an interpretational
question that needs to be just
rejiggered in the way we think about
quantum mechanics there's an issue that
wasn't there originally but that that
has cropped up and you're going to
disabuse us with all the silly thoughts
that have led us to think that this is
an issue
of course got it okay good all right so
what i want to do now is move into
the
possible solutions to this issue at
least for those who think that there is
so you know when you it's perhaps worth
saying when we talk about quantum
mechanics there is sort of one founding
father figure who really thought that he
had sorted this all out and this is this
guy here at niels bohr so when you talk
about it being a non-issue are you kind
of aligning yourself with
niels bohr's position
in that there basically needs to be a
clear separation between the quantum
description and the observer and the
observer needs to be part of that story
is that part of what you're going to
tell us um
i'm certainly bored that the observer or
let's say
the subject needs to be part of the
story
but um i mean was difficult to pin down
in
in what we actually said and meant and
certainly some aspects of wars thinking
would not be um
well i would not be good okay and you're
going to tell us about that in just a
moment all right so let's set up the the
issue and i think a useful way of doing
it
is to have a kind of concrete
example in mind and the example i'm
going to give you is just a very simple
thing of a dart being thrown into dart
board and we're going to revisit that
example in each of the proposed
solutions as we go forward not because
the visualization that we're going to
give you is spot-on accurate for that
you really need the mathematical
formalism but i think it's good to have
just a mental mnemonic of the ideas just
to try to keep them straight so the
example that i'm going to use if i if i
have my handy dart here yeah actually
can we bring the imag up for this guy if
you would just so people can see what it
is that i'm talking about yeah good yeah
bring it up here can you get that good
all right so i'm gonna take this guy
right i'm gonna throw this guy right and
there he goes so so classically right so
that is what that that is what isaac
newton says would happen right you
simply throw the dart god you're good
i'm good right all right all right
bullseye everybody has helped right so
so that's what isaac newton would say
that's what our intuition says the dart
simply flies through space and hits the
dart board okay now the
approach to quantum mechanics that came
down to us from niels bohr and the
approach that i was describing in the
early part of my remarks
describes this in a somewhat different
way so if we can go to the standard
quantum mechanical version
so here's the dart it turns into this
probability wave the wave spikes
collapses at the location where the dart
lands and that is the description in the
very standard copenhagen approach to
quantum mechanics so i think we can run
this guy a second time just so we have
this one in mind and the issue that we
have is this notion of the wave spiking
the wave collapsing there's no equation
that bohr gives us to this and therefore
this is something that we don't really
understand as a mathematical formalism
we want to go further and have something
that really relies on a quantitative
description of what's going on so the
first approach that we are going to take
a look at
shelley you have been charged with being
the defender if you will of this first
approach the de broglie boom approach so
in fact why don't we just give a little
bit of historical context first here we
got de bruy up there and then the other
culprit responsible for this david baum
take us through if you will their way of
thinking about what's going on in this
situation okay
i would say their way of thinking about
it pretty much conforms to the way
many people in the audience probably
understood
what you were saying in connection with
the two-slit experiment what did you see
happen in the two-slit experiment
you saw particles going out from the gun
one at a time and definitely saw dots
arriving at the screen appearing on the
screen one at a time an interference
pattern develops you have the strongest
very strong evidence that there's a wave
schroeder quickly found an equation for
that wave
and that equation predicts all kinds of
other stuff so we had good reason to be
extremely confident that
one element of quantum mechanics was
that wave
you also would have thought you had good
reason to think that as part of the
one in one element of the system
this one particle system is the particle
itself you're talking about a system
consisting of a particle there should be
a particle where particle means
something with a position so in addition
to the wave
according to the bohmian point of view
at the broly's point of view
you have
an actual particle which has a position
and the wave is not so much
fundamentally a probability wave but
what has often been called the guiding
wave the wave is relevant to the motion
of the particle in a very precise way so
that in addition to schrodinger's
equation you have another equation an
evolution equation for the particle or
for particles if there's more than one
the this this second equation which is
not standard is something which is so
sort of obvious that you could ask
your good students to guess it in almost
any way of guessing which is remotely
sensible would lead to the same answer
when you analyze that theory which has
the wave together with particle or
particles
you find to your surprise and it really
is it's a surprise that it yields all of
the standard predictions of quantum
mechanics probabilities and all despite
there's not the fact that there's
nothing random in the motion of this
system so just to understand so you got
particles and waves as opposed to the
traditional description is you've got to
wave until you look and then it becomes
a particle in this picture the wave is
actually pushing on the particle and
that's what describes its ultimate
motion you always got wave you've always
got particle it and it turns out after
analysis that the wave
turns out to function as a probability
wave it actually correctly describes the
probabilities which you'll for which
with which you'll find the particle in
various ways and you also find out quite
almost paradoxically that when you try
when you think about what you should
what you even mean by the wave for that
particle when it interacts with the
measuring device with the script with
the screen you find that this thing
really does collapse according to the
usual rules yep so we have a little
visual again just the mental mnemonic
for this one so if we go back to the
dart in this case
in your version the dart is always there
the wave pushes on it and that governs
where it lands so we can just see that
one again again it's wave and particle
so they're both there the dart is the
particle the wave pushes on it and
that's where it lands but it shouldn't
always be landing at the same place
so
how would we describe say the double
slit in this language so we had these
interfering waves in the picture that i
was showing governing the likelihood of
the particle landing one location or
another in in the double slit in this
case
what would be the motion
responsible for the interference pattern
built up by the little dots on the
screen
so so the particle
is guided by the wave
if
the
motion of the particle somehow leads to
an interference pattern that must be
being impressed on the particle from the
wave but the wave does indeed go through
both slits it does indeed develop an
interference pattern and in precisely
the distance from the two slits that the
way two pieces of wave one through the
upper slit one through the lower stick
when they start to overlap and interfere
and develop an interference pattern you
see that there you see the motion starts
to get interferency with the part with
the trajectories
tending to go in avoiding certain
regions and clustering in other regions
because they're guided by a wave which
has a similar structure right and just
to show
the equations you mentioned there's a
secondary equation which is how in
essence the wave pushes on the particle
you said any student could could guess
it
yeah does anybody want to guess
what the other equation is
if just in case so there it is right so
um
anybody could have guessed it absolutely
but it's actually true but when you
study the details of this this is the
natural equation that pops out you even
guessed it i i don't know if i guessed
it but uh i looked it up um so um no you
had your own derivation of it in your oh
that's true i did have my own derivation
you're absolutely right so thank you for
you you read the whole thing
footnotes and everything that's great
all right so this is this approach
and and you know the nice thing about
this is now particles always have
definite location they have trajectories
in the in the traditional sense which is
a very nice feature of this now other
folks what do you think about this sean
well uh david wallace philosopher of
physics uh put it in the way that i find
very compelling he says you know faced
with the measurement problem that we're
looking at here
uh the philosophers instantly want to
add new physics
the physicists are like we just need
better philosophy right
and so as a physicist like there's a
whole other equation a whole other thing
and as we'll get to i believe in a much
sparser leaner and meaner version of
quantum mechanics so i just think that
none of this is necessary and when you
get to things beyond a single particle
or a single dart when you get to the
wave function of the universe and
quantum fields it becomes much harder
for this formulation to even be written
down rudiger you have thoughts on this
approach well i mean this was i i i very
much agree with what sean said in
addition i would say that i would like
to come back to spooky action at a
distance because boomi mechanics
actually has explicitly discovered
spooky action at a distance if i do
something here the guiding wave changes
instantaneously it's serious if you have
a if i have an entangled
pair now the curious thing is that there
is no way
physically to actually
detect that change
over there well that's that's the other
way around if somebody does something
it's serious then the the the
the the boomian
real set of affairs the guiding way for
this at this place he has changes but
there is no physical way of actually
finding out what that change is or
finding out what the other person did
over there so for me this is a very
strong argument a very strong sign that
the physics tells me that this picture
is
wrong david unnecessary um
i'm i'm much more sympathetic to the
uh to the bohmian picture than
than either the previous two
um commenters were um but of course the
this
it's going to be what what we think of
any of these pictures is going to end up
depending on
what we have on the table
in front of us um i mean of the four
pictures we're going to discuss today
there's maybe a useful distinction to be
made three of them
are
in a very old-fashioned sense attempts
at an objective
univocal
realistic picture of what's going on in
the world that is the bohmian picture
the collapse picture which i'm going to
talk about a little bit and the the many
worlds picture that sean talks about um
are all
pictures in this tradition
the cubist picture is something
different the cubist picture is a way of
renouncing um this traditional objective
which will come realistic
so it depends on what else you have on
the table if
if um shawn's picture worked out at the
end of the day that is if there were a
way to make sense of our experience in
the context of this everettian
interpretation i think everything sean
says on its behalf would be crucial and
important i have worries that at the end
of the day it's not going to be possible
to make sense of our experience in the
context like that
given that
i think there are very good reasons
for um for pursuing the kind of bohmian
project that shelley described so if i
was to um
to uh ask you in the spirit of say
you know america's got talent right
to vote you know and voting here is not
saying that you think it's the right
answer but it's sufficiently promising
that it's worthy of further development
on this approach that shelley was
describing
how would you vote so if we can actually
bring up our little a little scoreboard
here so on this de broglie boom approach
david what say you yes yes so here we go
oh
yeah okay good all right
so sheldon i suspect no i don't like it
i'm going to vote for you yes there we
go okay good
sean
i think i was thumbs down yeah you think
you were remember the past well actually
um we thought we were trying to predict
what you would say you'd be like you
know
i said it was the second best maybe
maybe it would work all right so a
thumbs down to a maybe yeah
one
thumbs up thumbs down something in
between and you gotta you gotta say um
thumbs down because that's what's gonna
come up here but yeah
that's a probabilistic scoreboard and
there's a high probability that it's
going to come out thumbs down you see
the only thing i object with is saying
well not worth of further development
that is a very sort of i mean it's
almost unscientific thing to say so um
see the physicists are just as bad as
the philosopher
okay so uh no no but no no your
qualification is absolutely important
and people around the world have heard
it this is just sort of a very coarse
description of your perspective all
right so there there's our our first
approach and now what i want to do is
immediately move on to
the second vote why don't i vote
i'm meant to be the objective moderator
here but um
maybe i'll maybe i'll jump in
here or there at some point so the many
worlds approach to quantum mechanics a
completely different
solution to this measurement issue that
brings up a whole lot of other
fantastically interesting ideas
give us your best shot convincing us
that this is the way to think about it
oh you'll all be convinced there we go
the uh you know you gave this wonderful
quantum algorithm that we're all taught
in
physics undergraduate school you start
with a state of the universe a wave
function a quantum state
it evolves with time there's some
equation schrodinger's equation
and then if you were to make a
measurement the probability of getting a
measurement outcome is proportional to
the square of the amplitude that obeys
that equation okay so clearly it's step
three that is the embarrassment here
right it sounds different than anything
we've ever heard it's awkward or
whatever so many worlds is the following
you have a state quantum state of the
universe a wave function it obeys an
equation the same equation that we had
before schrodinger's equation now stop
talking
just shush that's it that's what the
many world says that's the entirety of
what we call the everett formulation of
quantum mechanics after hugh everett who
invented it there he is you everett and
uh it says you know
that the third step the step where the
probability comes in
that happens whether you put it in or
not that naturally emerges from the wave
function and its evolution and why does
that happen well you remember you had
the nice picture of looking for the
particle in manhattan and you said the
measuring device is going to measure and
if you just took naively seriously the
equation
the measuring device itself is in a
superposition so there's one part of the
wave function of the universe that says
the particle was here and the measuring
device found it there
there's another part of the wave
function says the particle somewhere
else in the measuring device saw it
somewhere else
and the everett formulation says
yes
believe the equation accept the equation
trust what that equation is telling you
and you want to match as david rightly
emphasizes you want to make sure
that that sort of you know giving into
the equation and letting it wash over
you actually matches our experience and
those of us who are everadians think
that it does so for a picture of that if
we go back to our little dart thing and
again criticize the image of us not
capturing the idea you know roughly
speaking but we might imagine that the
dart now is going towards the dart board
and what happens is in some sense it
lands in all of these different
locations in all of these different
realms these different universes if you
will and in this approach there's no
collapsing to one outcome all the
possibilities actually occur so we just
take a look at this guy again just to
have it in mind to compare with the
others you got the wave and the wave is
the wave like you said that's why the
wave is still waving over there because
nothing's happened the wave is still
describing what's going on that's right
it was crucial to this picture
especially to people who you know don't
hang out on the wrong street corners
where we discuss
quantum mechanics uh is that worlds we
have many worlds here well we have nine
here yep
they're not put in
by hand they were always there as
possibilities in the wave function all
that everett says is
take them seriously they're not added to
the theory there's nothing added to the
theory there's such a wave function and
an evolution equation and we live on one
of these and it's very much as if you
know the world where a stack of papers
you know a sheet of papers and all the
papers start out
the same and as time goes on they become
a little bit different and every one of
those is a separate world and people
don't like it
but
it was always there in quantum mechanics
so how was this received when it was
first put forward so you mean everyone
immediately said that must be right
what's that
uh the story that i was told was that
hugh everett was a graduate student at
princeton working with john wheeler and
he came up with this idea and you know
wheeler was a visionary physicist and an
uh old-school quantum mechanics guy
friends with niels bohr so he actually
sent his grad student everett to visit
niels bohr in copenhagen to like say
look i figured out quantum mechanics and
he came back so depressed that he left
physics because the uh reception that he
got was not encouraging and i think that
traditionally it's not been uh
encouraging it's been very difficult for
people to uh jump on the everettian
bandwagon but i think we have momentum
and i think especially it's because we
understand the dynamics of quantum
mechanics better and better we've
developed tools like decoherence and and
things like that we have seen in
experiments the kind of behavior that is
predicted by this idea that the wave
function is always there so i think that
it's just much easier now to believe in
the many worlds picture than it was 50
60. so can i just ask you one question
that comes in and it's a natural
question i'm sure people here but this
is from elizabeth
s in tennessee
how can there be many worlds we can't
see how is that different
from
thinking about god or angels
we have an equation if we had an
equation for god and angels
i might believe in them
you know again
it is again a very good question you're
right because
what right do we have to accept the
existence of all these things that we
all admit we will never
see
and the answer it really is that is what
the equation predicts and by accepting
that equation i find a set of
predictions that match i would claim
perfectly onto every experiment we've
ever done here in the world i think it
had to be our job as scientists to
develop the simplest most powerful most
comprehensive theory of the world that
fits the data and that's what many
worlds is and the worlds are there you
don't you don't count the ontological
extravagance of a theory by counting the
number of worlds in it you count it by
the number of equations in it and i have
the fewest equations of anyone up here
[Laughter]
david what do you think
uh well you know the worry i mean this
is this is
everett's original proposal was one of
the most sort of radical and heroic
and
thrilling and seductive i think
proposals in the history of science
um um
there are all kinds of reasons to get
very excited about it and i don't know
anyone
who i think of as smart who hasn't gone
who who knows about this stuff who
hasn't spent a good amount of time very
excited about this interpretation the
question at the end of the day this is
something that sean alluded to i mean
the the
place around which most of the worries
about the edward interpretation have
coalesced over the years is whether it
can make sense
of
of the chanciness of our experience of
the world this chanciness is absolutely
crucial to the way we verify quantum
mechanics quantum mechanics makes
certain predictions about the
probabilities of the outcomes of
experiments we do many such experiments
like you were showing in the
introduction we we gather up frequency
information for how these experiments
come out and it's on the basis of these
sorts of collections of experiments that
we take ourselves to have good reason to
believe in quantum mechanics in the
first place like i say
the point around which most of the
worries have coalesced over the years is
whether
something like the everett
interpretation can make sense of those
probabilities and the very
simple way of saying where the worries
come from is just to point out that this
picture of the world is completely
deterministic given the way things start
out given the initial wave function of
the world it's possible to predict by
solving the equations exactly what the
world is going to look like at all
future times there will be this
branching structure i will in some sense
have many different descendants but it's
all you that are all me
but it's not clear how it it's going to
make sense to assign probabilities to my
ending up as this one or that one the
worry is that it would be like saying to
an amoeba that's about to split do you
think you're going to end up as the one
on what do you think the chances are
that you're going to end up on the right
or or is the one on the left it seems
like the right answer for the amoeba to
give is gee that's a stupid question
probabilities aren't involved here at
all i'm for sure going to have one
descendant that's on the right i'm for
sure going to have one descendant that's
on the left
that seems like at least very naively
there's a long history of discussions of
this sean has contributed to it lately
in a really interesting way
but there's been this worry from the
beginning that probability talk just
isn't going to make sense if it doesn't
make sense this is not a theory that can
account for our empirical experiences so
basically if i if i'm the experimenter
in the lab right and there's a 50 chance
i found the electron here 50 chance that
i find it there i do the measurement in
this approach i am going to see the
electron over there and another one of
me is going to see the electron over
there so if i ask myself what's the
probability say that i'm going to see it
over there it's not 50 percent it's a
hundred percent because there will be a
me who sees it over there right and if i
ask what's the probably i see it on the
left a hundred percent not fifty percent
because there will be a version of me
that sees it what say to that sean well
i think it's exactly the right thing to
focus in on in the ever interpretation
unsurprisingly since david knows what
he's talking about i always worry when
david says i made an interesting
contribution but
thank you
um but it and what i would what i would
say is that quantum mechanics the many
worlds picture of quantum mechanics
challenges us because the way
probability works in this theory is
different than the way it has ever
worked and roughly speaking we talk
about objective probabilities and
subjective probabilities and objective
probabilities just there is something
irreducibly random and chancy and david
will uh in the dynamical collapse
theories defend that point of view
subjective theories are there's
something subjective probabilities
there's something that's going to happen
but we don't know because we lack some
information and shelly and rodinger will
defend views like that and the everett
formulation says well actually it's kind
of neither one of those which shouldn't
be surprising because quantum mechanics
often says that that's the answer
everett says we know exactly the entire
state of the universe a hundred percent
accurately in principle there's nothing
probabilistic about it it evolves
deterministically
but there are circumstances like the
dart hitting the dartboard imagine that
i didn't see the dart hit the dartboard
yeah okay so now there's a branch where
the dart hit there don't hit there
there and there's many copies of me
i know everything there is to know about
the universe but i don't know which copy
i am
so that's a kind of subjective
probability that arises naturally from
the objective deterministic evolution
and all of your copies can say the same
thing they will and we'll argue that
there is one unique sensible way for
them to behave and it turns out to
precisely fit the data you mean if were
betting on the outcomes what would be
the smart bet to make and somehow it all
works out that if they bet according to
the probabilities as usually calculated
they'll maximize the return something
like that that's one way of doing it i
mean like many right answers there are
many different ways to derive it but yes
we get the right answer gotcha rude of
your thoughts on on many worlds
well
you've converted you just realized
in which universe
my worry is that
in the theory in which
everything happens
um we are actually not saying anything
about the world we're in
that's really it thank you
shelly thoughts many worlds
i was once sympathetic to it
it does have the virtue of having and it
hurt you of having one equation
boom has two equations
standard quantex but quantum mechanics
has uh maybe an infinite number of
equations because it's never really
fully written down yeah
so having just one equation is very nice
my problem with it i have two problems
basically with maybe more than two um
one is it's not so much that i don't see
how probabilities can arise in the
theory in a way that would
that we would see random results in some
sense but rather that i just don't have
the sense that the probabilities really
come out convincingly
not at all convincing i would i would
have expected different probabilities
according to that theory than the usual
ones but that's not my that isn't so
much my main difficulty my main
difficulty is i have a sense that it's
based
on a mistake
a mistake everybody took almost all
physicists just somehow took for granted
that is taking the wave function
as
the only
element of the reality the only thing
that's real and for a quantum system is
its wave function if as soon as you say
you've got more than wave function
well then there's no need whatsoever for
many worlds and what i find striking is
that that
this dogma that the way function is
everything even extends to
so many many physicists who
don't regard the wave function is real
at all
many physicists
it's
far less than a majority of physicists
that take the wave function seriously as
something objective real
when they say many physicists when they
say it's a probability wave they really
mean just
just reflects our information it's
subjective not something really out
there
nonetheless
many of those same physicists will still
say but there's nothing more than wave
which would seem to suggest it's nothing
[Laughter]
the simplest solution of all so that's
going to be a problematic theory all
right so if we can go back to our little
chart a little scoreboard just to uh get
a sense here so so david on many worlds
is it is it worthy of further pursuit
you think it could ultimately be yeah i
i'm sympathetic to this claim that one
doesn't want to ever say about anything
that oh you've got it i'm further than
you but i i'm i'm
i'm willing to accept the thumbs down
thank you
jelly
thumbs down might be a little bit too
strong but i know i think you're a
pretty strong guy you know
yeah that's good well done in the booth
thank you
sean i i assume
thumbs up two thumbs up i don't know if
we can do that uh but we'll definitely
come back to it rudiger well i think
there's hardly a doubt about what that
will come out
chunk there it is all right
so
two two proposals let's move on to the
third one and and david that's one that
you're going to describe to us which is
spontaneous collapse so
this approach is more or less
especially given the way the problem is
usually set up and given the way you set
the problem up here
this is the sort of most
pedestrian straightforward obvious
first thing to think of and that is look
you solve the equations of motion as
they're given to us they give us this
weird result where there's a
superposition of seeing this and seeing
that as you said our experience doesn't
at least in so far as we understand it
look anything like that um when we do
these experiments so the obvious thing
to do is to think about modifying
these equations
the the rough idea of doing something
like that because it's so obvious goes
very far back i mean you find this in
schrodinger
in the in the 30s
you find it in
in von neumann's
famous book mathematical foundations of
quantum mechanics
but
the way von neumann formulated it for
example
was to say okay apparently there are two
laws
rather than one about how the wave
function evolves and they apply in
different circumstances
when the system of interest isn't being
measured it evolves according to these
to the schrodinger equation which which
you put up before
when the system is being measured
it evolves instead according to this
postulate which dictates that the wave
function collapses into the sharp peak
around whatever result
is obtained
good
as it stands
this this just doesn't count as a
serious candidate for a fundamental
theory of the workings of nature it
involves this english word measurement
it depends on whether or not a
measurement is going on and at least the
ordinary english meaning of that word
isn't remotely doesn't have remotely the
requisite precision to play this kind of
role in a fundamental picture of nature
so
a problem arose
about
a question arose about how to precisely
delineate the boundary between those
circumstances in which the schrodinger
equation
governed the evolution of the wave
function of the world and those
circumstances in which a collapsed
postulate
govern the evolution
of the wave function of the world and
the history of discussions of trying to
locate this boundary for something like
50 years i think it has to be said
is a kind of
you know wince inducing
um
very undistinguished discussion in the
history of physics so you have people
invoking all kinds of other vague words
that are clearly no better than
measurement
you have people invoking distinctions
between the micro and the macro in order
to locate this boundary or between
reversible processes and irreversible
processes in order to locate this
boundary or between
animate systems and inanimate systems in
order to locate this boundary or between
subject and object
in order to locate this boundary it
presumably should have been clear to
everybody
from the word go
that none of these other distinctions
was going to be any sharper was going to
be any more useful than the original
distinction that van neumann was talking
about between circumstances in which
measurement is going on and
circumstances in which measurement isn't
going on and like i say the discussion
went around in sort of pathetic circles
like this
for about half a century or more
until the early 1980s when finally
three italian physicists girardi
romanian weber
actually wrote down a fully explicit
mathematically precise
theory of collapse the theory didn't end
up working in exactly the way all these
previous discussants that is wigner and
von neumann and bohr and those people
had anticipated that is it didn't do
something like locate a sharp boundary
between those circumstances in which
collapse occurs and it doesn't rather
they modified the schrodinger equation
in a way that applies to every single
physical system at all times but they
came up with an extremely clever way to
modify it that had the consequence that
um
for all situations except the situations
that are characteristic of measurement
or a little bit more generally for all
situations except situations where
you're dealing with a macroscopic object
that's in a superposition of two
different spatial locations for all
situations
other than those their modified equation
gave almost identical results to the
standard schrodinger equation but they
came up with a way of modifying it such
that in those troublesome situations it
departed dramatically
from the predictions of the schrodinger
equation and actually gave you something
like a collapse of the wave function as
you were talking about onto one of these
peaks or another so like i say the basic
idea here was around from the beginning
this is the most flat-footed and obvious
way to respond to the measurement
problem as it usually presented it took
a long long time for somebody to make
these ideas precise and we doubt we now
do have this
very
simple straightforward
elegant mechanism due to girardi romani
so as i understand it basically so when
it comes to individual particles like a
single electron right they behave more
or less very close to the
standard approach very very close but
the idea is you've got many particles
many electrons and quarks and neutrons a
big collection of particles there's a
new physical phenomenon that kind of
hits one of those particles causes its
probability wave to spike or collapse
and then downfall
the whole thing then exactly
materializes in a definition that's
exactly right that's exactly right he
taught me this that's why i get it right
so um so just to give you a sense we
have a little a little visual of this so
again back to our dart and the idea is
we'll hit this guy with that
collapse right new equation that new
phenomenon just dictated sort of by that
little flashing light there and then
sort of as you're saying downfall the
dominoes and the whole thing
materializes and that's the new way of
thinking about in this grw or
spontaneous collapse approach i think we
have this guy a second time just to run
this guy through again so again it's a
probability wave wave function you have
this new phenomenon from grw's collapses
on a particle and that causes all of the
other ones to collapse as well giving us
this definite outcome so we basically
are taking the old idea and making it
happen with and and making making it
explicit and making it precise um
reformulating this old idea so that it
doesn't depend on words like measurement
or macroscopic rather
of course it's a consequence of this
theory that macroscopic objects don't
remain in superpositions that
measurements have determinate outcomes
but that's not because words like
measurement or macroscopic are playing
any role in the fundamental formulation
of the theory rather that's something we
can prove about these things from an
exact fundamental formulation of the
theory such as gerardi romania and vapor
gabriel write down
rudiger thoughts on this approach
well
it's
let's just say something about all three
which they have in common because um
david earlier said that cubism stands
out so they're all they have in common
the following view
of the world of
of reality there is let's say you you
know the state of the world right now
that determines
especially for all the future
what the probabilities for
future events for anything that happens
in the future will be
so this is actually very similar to to a
19th century view
to the 19th century
deterministic view where they see let's
they said that plus this view where um
if
if if you knew the state of the world
now you could you could predict exactly
what what happens at any stage in the
future with this
with the one difference
which is important of course but really
not that radical that what we predict in
these three theories is not
the precise things that happen but just
the probabilities
so um in that sense um i mean this is
just one particular view of the world
and so um what cubism does is
finally comes in about three minutes is
this word all
night explore a different a different
route a different
a different view of the world and so
this is this is really one one one
reason for for for
not wanting to pursue grw
sean quick thoughts on uh
spontaneous collapse yeah i resonate
with you at all it's one of those things
that certainly could be true uh but if
it turned out to be true i would
probably retire as a physician
um and this is something where you know
any of these could be why it's just too
ugly or well it's it's it seems to
just come along with all sorts of weird
and unnecessary things um for one thing
the past and the future are radically
different in a theory like this right uh
then they had and one of the great
triumphs of
physics from newton through super string
theory is that the past and future are
on an equal footing
it's an intrinsically probabilistic law
which i think that we can get away from
uh it's a sort of a
recipe that works in the situation of
darts or electrons doesn't work in any
obvious way for the real world which is
made of quantum fields or quantum
spacetime or something like that and
maybe someone could find something like
that but it seems to be repudiating
therefore so much of the success of the
last 100 years of physics for what i
don't you know is pushing on an open
door i don't think that we need all that
extra stuff to solve the problems kelly
one thing that perhaps should be said i
don't know if it was said that unlike
the other approaches mentioned here this
is not so much a criticism not really a
criticism but this
grw spontaneous localization is in fact
it's different in the sense that it
makes different predictions from quantum
mechanics well all the other
possibilities that's a key point making
exactly the same predictions presumably
anyway they're claimed to make the same
prediction
this makes different particular so in
that sense it's it's fundamentally it's
so it's a different theory and in
principle you can i would say all of
those things are probably different
theories but yeah other three of them
are paragliding you can make you can you
can design experiments in principle
these experiments are difficult to do
with currently available technology but
in principle we know how to design
experiments
for which
um grw or any of the similar family of
theories of spontaneous collapses will
give different predictions than than
either bomb or everett
or cubism let me mention too what i
think has two problems with it one is
the modification of schrodinger's
equation is pretty ad-hoc
secondly notice i i didn't write that
one down because
that one is you know basically sean is
saying it's too much of a pain to write
it down too many features to actually
even too much arbitrariness yes i agree
second
one of the most beautiful equations is
quantum mechanics is schroeder's
equation you lose that nice equation
yep
all right so yeah yeah guys i should say
very quickly by the way that uh the the
three theories we have here that attempt
to make the same predictions
uh or purportedly make the same
predictions do so because they're cooked
up
to fit the data the experiments we've
already done as a cosmologist who spends
time thinking about the whole universe
much of which doesn't have any observers
in it i think that our theories are
different in those regimes when you
don't have measurements going on i think
that's very very important for modern
cosmology yep yeah absolutely all right
so
back to our quick chart if we can just
get a sense here david what do you say
about this approach
i think it's worth pursuing you think
it's worth pursuing yes okay we guessed
it right
shelly
yeah i think it's worth pursuing yep all
righty
sean
a healthy thing but uh no unless you
want to retire
yeah i know it's worth other people
pursuing
i i give you a
yeah i think it's reasonable
well it's it's a testable theory so
worth pursuing good all right so we are
now
to our final
candidate
cubism so we've heard this word
a few times mentioned rudiger tell us
what this approach is about okay i
bought a quantum system
to um to do an experiment on so that
just
flipped this quantum system
okay so what's what's the probability of
heads
hundred percent uh many worlds approach
uh okay
i'm sorry
let me play along fifty percent
what was that what you want me to say
i i i played along with me i'll play
along with you stick with a hundred
percent
i have zero percent okay
okay my point being the probability you
have a different one for me so this is
actually about you and about me it's not
about the system directly so the
probability actually is
your belief or my belief about what you
will see if i show it to you i can show
it to you you see it
he was right yeah
so take us a little further so i uh
understand what this is about
so probability in this in in this is i
mean
just an example for her probability is
is
is used in in bayesian personalis
probability theory which actually is
a modern
full account of probability which is
used in
widely in
in statistics economics and some parts
of physics so
this is a
is a is respected and very useful and
actually i believe the only really fully
consistent approach of probability
probability is
belief about what you will experience
what you will see now what cubism says
is that
you you do not need to modify the
concept of probability of quantum
mechanics so even quantum mechanics
probabilities are
personal degrees of belief one so they
basically the probability i write down
for a measurement outcome is my
um
is my expectation of what i will
experience when i perform the experiment
so the point is the probability is not a
property of this coin this is how my
hand the probability is actually my
belief
and
now quantum states
are equivalent to probabilities
quantum states determine
probabilities of outcomes quantum states
are fully mathematically equivalent to
probability distributions so in that
sense
probabilities are an experimenters or an
agent's expectations or quantum states
sorry excel probabilities or quantum
states quantum states encode and
experimenters or agents expectations for
experimental outcomes
now what that says about the measurement
problem is that it just
dissolves
because probability theory has no
measurement problem
um as a collapse problem
when i when i uh write on a probability
for for some experiment i observe the
outcome but nothing collapses it
probably just
becomes useless because i mean has done
its job and
and you don't need it any longer or if
you have a situation where you actually
um just get partial data and want to
update probabilities for for the future
all you do is you update your own
expectations for the future but nothing
in the world collapses and you update
them by the observations we themselves
exactly i i experience an outcome update
my own expectations for the future so
can we give a little visual mental
mnemonic okay for this one so this
fourth approach is the dart is going and
the idea is
if we're not looking if we're not
actually yet doing the observation
there's there's nothing really we can
say until the observer looks and so
there if we bring our our observers
rudiger takes a look and then you look
and you take in the observation you
update your understanding of the world
based on your observation is that sort
of uh roughly capturing what you're
saying well um why i
i got a told in times square to do that
i thought i thought i did a pretty good
likeness uh not bad right yes
like 10 bucks you can do it anyway go
ahead
well you see
oh
um when we do science what are we doing
we're making predictions
and um we um we we test these
predictions and experiments
so this is really what cubism talks
about quantum mechanics is i mean this
this must be the reason why most
physicists are not interested in the
interpretations of quantum mechanics it
is because quantum mechanics is a tool
they can use to make predictions to
design experiments to build machines to
build
um i mean
quantum mechanics has transformed the
world in in a way that has i mean that
is that is
unprecedented now in all these in all
these experiments
experimental designs predictions
including cosmological predictions
you never actually need to talk about
booming about bohmian
hidden variables about spontaneous
collapse not even multiply function of
the universe
you you just apply quantum mechanics as
a tool to make predictions to verify
these predictions and that works and
this must be the reason why most
visitors are not interested in the in
the interpretation of quantum accounts
so what do you say to people that would
be just you know have some discomfort
about this imagine what the universe was
like before there were
observers right so no one was having any
of these experiences is does your
approach
somehow
give a description of the world that
would make me comfortable
about it happening out there even if
there's nobody looking at it is that
something that i should well i would
hope so because when you do cosmology
what are your basic cosmology on you
base it on what you observe or
experience now i mean this is really all
you you you can base your theory or your
thinking or your cosmology on what um
what is what are the cosmological
predictions or your conclusions you draw
well they are if they're a good
cosmology they're about your future
experience they're about your future
predictions i mean you would you you
will never stop at just saying well i
have explained how the things are now
because there may be many things the
ways of doing is you test your
cosmology by making predictions and then
for instance about the
particular fluctuations in the
background radiation and you test them
so even cosmology is um is about taking
your present and the theopath
experiences
and
and
using the theory using quantum mechanics
as you know it to make predictions about
future experiences so it fits perfectly
well into that into that framework now
i'll give everybody a shot in a minute
to give your thoughts on this one thing
that you mentioned early on was spooky
action at a distance
and
let's just come to that now because it's
interesting to see what cubism says
about this so the traditional way of
thinking about it if we could bring up
our system so imagine
uh we have these two arrows it's called
spin a half in in quantum physics but
imagine that we have these two entangled
particles whose spins are up and down
but in a correlated manner now the
traditional spooky action at a distance
arises if i go and i measure say the
particle on the left right and through
my measurement i cause it to take a
definite reality say spinning up then
according to the mathematics the distant
particle also snaps out of this fuzzy
haze of possibilities and spins down and
that's weird because i did my
measurement over here but i seem to have
an impact over there this is what
einstein called spooky now
in your approach the spookiness
evaporates if i understand it can you
describe to us where it goes
well
i should have won different color socks
here because in the cubist approach
these correlations these spooky these
this situation is very much like
battlement socks
burtleman was a colleague of belle i
think at the university of vienna i'm
not exactly sure about that and he
used to wear different colored socks and
so when belle saw him coming around the
corner when he saw one foot one sock he
knew immediately what the color of the
other sock would be namely different
so um
so nobody would call it spooky action at
the distance
so what um what what cubism says here is
that if if i have a belief about these
two because this is what the quantum
state is this this is this is a belief
about what i will see experience when i
make an experiment on this on that
particle here
so
what happens is if i if i make
a
measurement on this particle here
i see it
experience spin down i see spin down and
then i update my expectation
for the other particle here now of
course people now to get the information
of the other particle it has to somehow
travel to you the result of that
experiment well for instance oh i have
to go over there and oh you go over
there and you look at it so there's
nothing happening at a distance because
if it's all about what you observe you
are certainly always nearby your own
self and therefore there's no spooky
action at a distance because it's all
about you
um it is not all about me it's about i
mean you you mentioned or each observer
no
even not that it is it is always about
me and the world because because i mean
cubism emphatically says not that it is
all about the subject
nor is it all about the world any
measurement is an action
a subject an observer a physicist system
takes on the world and um and so so
measurements are active processes
they're they're actions um but it's
actually elicit an experience and the
measurement outcomes
ask them is the experience so any
measurement any measurement
is an action on the world and it needs
the subject and the object it needs it's
where the experience
um
and and the world meet but that
experience is something that that the
individual the observer has that's the
point yeah good so
what do you think david
in the beginning of quantum mechanics
there were figures like
bohr
who announced that something really
earth-shaking had occurred
um not just that that the world was
different than we thought it was
but that but that
the world was in a fundamental and
irrevocable way
less susceptible to scientific
penetration as it were
than we used to think
that
that the project that the old-fashioned
scientifically realist project of
representing the world
you know of of giving the view from
nowhere as it were of giving a universal
objective factual representation of what
the world was doing from which all of
our experience could be derived
figures like bohr announced that the
really profound lesson of quantum
mechanics was not this or that lesson
about how atoms behaved but a much
deeper much more earth-shaking lesson to
the effect that this whole set of
aspirations
had somehow been exposed as quaint and
naive and old-fashioned and outmoded
okay and when people said
but shouldn't we look harder for
some way of rep some way of
understanding
an actual picture of the facts of the
world from which all this would follow
what they were told again and again
was that was that there were proofs that
there were arguments these proofs go
back to von neumann
bohr thought he had arguments along
these lines so on and so forth that no
such thing was available okay if this is
the case
this is indeed
a sort of unspeakably profound moment in
the history of human thought
what's happened since then
is that it's been discovered that these
announcements of the death of this
project were in all sorts of ways
premature okay
we now have
perfectly old-fashioned
realistic models
of the world which explain the emergence
of our experience okay they're they're
i take it
nobody on this stage has so far claimed
that say
bohr and grw
don't do that the complaints have bought
it is good
bowman bowman jrw excuse me bowman grw
don't do that there's some question
about whether ever it does that or not
some people say yes
some people say no but there doesn't
seem to be any dispute that there's a
possibility of doing that the complaints
about some of these realistic theories
are they're too complicated they have
two equations instead of one blah blah
blah blah this seems like fairly small
potatoes compared to the existence of a
comprehensible external world at all
okay so
now that we have these other examples it
just seems crazy there's a there's a
interesting project of this of comparing
these realistic theories to one another
of finding out which one works best of
finding out which one best satisfies our
taste for elegance and simplicity and so
on and so forth but the idea that
because some of these theories have two
equations rather than one the
appropriate conclusion is to give up on
the existence or comprehensibility
of the external world at all seems crazy
to me
so your real thoughts on
i think you want to respond i think i
would like to like to to respond i think
i have to say at least three things the
the claim that uh
the realistic psycho-realistic theories
explain experience
is bold
is right bold
um it's i mean i i don't think that
anything they don't explain why the
come out the way they do the second
second point is that
cubism does give a comprehensive
comprehensive view of of
the entirety of my external world it's
just it's just an agent-dependent world
so every agent
can explain all aspects of experience
all aspects of the external world
using quantum mechanics so
furthermore um there is sort of a
copernican principle um i can use
quantum mechanics to
to to to um to describe or to make
predictions about you you can uh
use quantum mechanics to make
predictions about me so there are no
aspects of the world which are beyond
quantum mechanics in the sense
and the third point or maybe the fourth
point is that um
it is uh
cubism does not give up
the um
the project of saying something about
the world and saying something objective
about the world it's just
cubism says something different about
the world
than what your project
is namely mapping parts of your
mathematical theory or mathematical
objects to
the reality of the world giving this
one-to-one mapping so
cubism has a different project and the
maybe one of the biggest
clues that might be on the right track
is that
none of these additions to quantum
mechanics that you find in grw are in
in bohmian mechanics are actually
necessary to use quantum mechanics to do
quantum mechanics to explain
all the experiments that have been done
in the in the in the last 90 years so
even
explanations and comprehensibility are
not sacrificed here so we're uh we're
two minutes over so we have to wrap this
up in about one minute i just want to
finish out our little table and then i
want to ask one final question before we
wrap it up i am going to vote on this
one uh i the the part about your
approach which i find quite compelling
is looking squarely at probability and
trying to use a better understanding of
it to give us a better understanding of
how it applies to quantum mechanics so
whether or not the particular approach
that you've come up with is the right
one or not we don't know of course but
i'm going to give it a thumbs up as an
approach that i think really is worthy
of further development david what what
do you say about cubism look once again
there's been an enormous amount of work
that's come out of cubism
about understanding the mathematical
relations among various probabilities
that we encounter in quantum mechanics i
think this has been enormously useful um
so i think there have been you know
my attitude toward this i guess is that
it's a project whose core vision
seems to me very confused and poorly
motivated but but which has had lots of
spin-offs
which have been great um
um so i guess if the question is do i
think of it as promising
as as an attempt to solve the
fundamental riddles of quantum mechanics
no do i think it's had useful and
illuminating spin-offs
yes many great um but i don't think we
even need to go to the chart because
late
because i don't know that we would
capture the nuance
so
yeah and thumbs just don't quite cut it
anymore
thoughts on this approach i pretty much
i totally agree with
david the
there ought to be room in physics for
discuss
for understanding what's in the world
and how it behaves even if there are no
agents in it agents are very interesting
and we like to understand agents and
their cowboy prizes for understanding
agents
but that understanding of agents is
often in terms of inanimate stuff not in
terms of other agents
john
you know i think
it's probably true that i just don't
understand cubism or quantum solidism as
well as i should but it seems to me that
one needs in that approach some
mechanism for talking about the wave
function and how it evolves
and the difference is that
in in our approaches we take that wave
function or whatever extra bits we have
and we say that's the real world this is
this is some description of reality and
in cubism it's just a tool
that you know if you were to take the
ever-ready and calculational schema and
did cubism on it you would say yes
there's all these other branches of the
wave function that are predicted by
schroedinger's equation and the way that
we deal with them is saying but they're
not real
we don't need to talk about them and
that seems more like therapy than
physics to me and i don't as i said
before i think it's necessary you're in
new york though therapy is a big big
thing here and it can go on for years so
uh final final question as you wrap it
up imagine we're at the world science
festival i don't know 20 25 20 50 i
don't know 2100 whatever
will we have an answer will there be
consensus on this are we just going to
continue with various ideas and is that
what the future will hold
david what do you think
look i think that because of some of the
history i described before
the serious discussion
of these questions
isn't more than about 20 years old now
the serious widespread discussion of
these questions the questions came up a
hundred years ago now
there was a long period of people
sitting in their bathtubs having
very idle and pointless discussions
about this so i think the the the
serious discussion of this
only only got started in the last 20
years yeah i think there's every reason
to be optimistic
that a hundred years from now there'll
be a consensus rudiger what do you think
well um david murman who is a
collaborator on this on this project in
in an email
the answer that he he sees me on said
well his prediction was that 25 years
from now um everybody would have
accepted cubism as the answer and so the
uh the field of quantum foundation would
uh would have sort of faded away all
right shelley i think more likely than
there'll be consensus on this is that in
by the year 2100 quantum mechanics will
have been completely replaced by some
totally different radical answer
what do you say sean yeah i think 50
years from now 97 of working physicists
and philosophers will agree on one
formulation of quantum mechanics
all right so come back to the world
science of 2100 to see if the
predictions are worn out please join me
in thanking tonight
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
no no no no no no no no no
[Music]